hey guys good morning hey guys we just
went for our Visa interviews for the USA
yes we did but the main reason we're
sending you guys this video is because
we're so busy this last uh few weeks
with everything that's going on we
wanted to include you in one of our
Bible studies a few weeks ago we shared
a video of what a a normal day in my
life looks like you know running two
YouTube channels and the whole Ministry
the is in the video as well you can
watch that video on DM Mains live style
we've got a good de meeting that that
we're going to share yeah but on that
video I had a Bible study with the team
and I didn't share everything with you
and I thought how about I invite you
guys to join us in that Bible study M so
here we
go